on may 1st 1776
five men gathered around the table in
ingolstadt bavaria
leading them was a local professor of
canon law the 28 year old
adam weishaupt they gathered to
inaugurate a new secret society
the order of perfectabilists
its name soon changed to the order of
the illuminati
or in german the illuminati order
the order of the enlightenment its totem
was the owl of minerva
or athena the ancient goddess of wisdom
another symbol
was a dot in a circle representing the
all-seeing eye
not the all-seeing eye of god but of the
mysterious
unknown superiors to whom the order
answered
the day may first marked an ancient
fertility festival
and it was the extension of the
preceding walpurgis knight
long associated with witchcraft and evil
spirits
vice house tiny order had grand ambition
their aim was to make men free
and happy but first they had to make
them good
vice hopped envisioned nothing less than
a world revolution that would result in
a universal republic
a new world order this necessitated
destruction of christianity and
all other forms of religion it also
meant the annihilation of all
governments
the new order would bring liberation
from all social
moral and religious restraint and
embrace absolute equality and social
fraternity
religious superstition would be replaced
with atheism for the masses
and a kind of enlightened pantheism for
the higher classes
a communism of goods would govern
economics
the benevolent enlightened elite the
illuminati
would reign over this earthly paradise
as weishaupt put it the superiors of
luminism are to be looked upon
as the most perfect and the most
enlightened of men
no doubts are to be entertained even of
their infallibility
down with the old masters say hello to
the new masters
i bet that even if you've never taken
notice of secret societies before
you've heard of the illuminati well over
two centuries later the term is embedded
in popular culture
as the generic name for a conspiratorial
group
bent on world domination people pour
over
super bowl ads looking for hidden
illuminati symbols
and they're even parodied in taco bell
commercials
the bavarian illuminati have spawned a
cottage industry of conspiracy theory
in this lecture we're going to explore
the roots of vice hope's creation
what it believed what it did and its
legacy
perhaps its survival the illuminati were
very much a creature of the 18th century
enlightenment
a time that well it's mostly identified
with the flowering of reason and science
also saw an explosion of interest in
mysticism in the occult
the century that produced the french
philosopher's
roll rousseau and voltaire
also gave us the italian forger and
swindler
alessandro caleostro the german
hypnotist
friedrich anton mesmer and the ageless
alchemist
the count of saint germain
there is nothing new about vice house
utopian vision
the term illuminati has been used many
times before
in the classical age any initiate of a
mystery cult was considered
an illuminatus the same was true for a
christian who'd undergone baptism
in essence what vice helped envisioned
was the realization of heaven on earth
the immanentizing of the eshaitan
that notion goes back a long long time
a fifth century persian prophet named
mazdak
imagined something much the same another
version
is the millennial paradise that many
believe christ will usher in on his
return
or the perfect kingdom jews anticipate
with the messiah
[Music]
the difference is that vice health's
perfect kingdom
would be instituted by humans themselves
at least the illuminated ones
vice hope's original contribution to
this ancient theme
was organization as opposed to
open proselytizing mass movements and
direct confrontation
he advocated secrecy or more to the
point
conspiracy the great strength of our
order lies in its concealment he decreed
let it never appear in any place in its
own name
but always covered by another name and
another occupation
besides vice house lack of originality
there was a question of whether he was
the real master of his conspiracy
or the tool of something bigger occult
and masonic scholar
manly p hall claimed that the bavarian
illuminati
were but a fragment of a larger movement
hall viewed vice helped as a faithful
servant of a larger cause
and that behind him moved the intricate
machinery
of the secret schools hall warned that
the mystery schools
never trust their full weight to any
perishable institutions
the bavarian illuminati were a chapter
in a story
not the whole story outwardly
vice health and his brethren came
nowhere near to achieving their lofty
ambitions
the bavarian illuminati officially
lasted barely a decade
the group is easy to dismiss as another
of history's countless failed pipe
dreams
but it's not as simple as that the
illuminati were never
rounded up or brought to account vice
helped
lib to write plot and influence until
his death in 1830
at the ripe age of 82. nor was the
society's organization
seriously disrupted after all it was
invisible
remember weishaupt decreed that the
order's strength lay in concealment
and that it would always appear under
other names
how do you ban that like other secret
societies in history such as the
templars
assassins cathars and still more before
them
there's every reason to suppose that the
illuminati carried on
in one form or another you could argue
that being exposed
was the best thing that ever happened to
the illuminati
there's no such thing as bad publicity
spread the name of the order far and
wide
people who might never have heard of it
now did
and as many were intrigued as repulsed
some even argue that weishaupt himself
blew the order's cover for precisely
that reason
in other words it was part of his plan
so who was adam weishaupt
his full name was johann adam joseph
weisshoft
he was not jewish as some have claimed
nor was he a jesuit priest or any kind
of religious figure
he was the son of a lawyer who died
young
and left his son's upbringing in the
hands of a godfather
baron johann from ichthaf
and ikshdof was the embodiment of an
enlightenment scholar
as lay director of the jesuit-run
university
of ingolstadt
he possessed a large library of
forbidden and esoteric books
to which young adam had early and ready
access
doubtless he learned a few things
at age 15 adam entered engelstadt
university
and followed his late father in the
study of law
he graduated in 1768 age
20 and right away assumed a
professorship
at the same school he was a hometown boy
made good
he seemed a typical member of the german
intellectual establishment
vice house jesuit instructors were noted
for the rigorousness of their education
a part of this was the notion of
casualty
it was the use of rational argument to
back up dubious deceptive or
self-serving conclusions
especially moral ones simply put
the art of propaganda weishaupt learned
an
important but often overlooked lesson
the voice of reason
isn't the one telling you to show mercy
it's the one telling you not to leave
any witnesses
the jesuits were basically a secret
society within the catholic church
under the absolute authority of their
superior general
they fought the enemies of the church by
all means fair and foul
political conspiracy even assassination
was their stock and trade
much like the medieval knights templars
the amassed
wealth and power
and like the templars this aroused envy
and fear
in the templars case it ended in
accusations of heresy and blasphemy
the jesuits nearly suffered the same
fate
in 1773 pope clement xiv
was persuaded to abolish the jesuits
for weishaupt this meant opportunity in
englishdot he ascended to
deacon of canon law weisshof later
expressed both disdain
and admiration for his jesuit mentors
his later position at the head of the
illuminati
directly mimicked the autocratic power
of the superior general arguably
the whole plan of the illuminati even
its secretiveness
was taken straight from the jesuit
playbook
thus some suspected that weisshoft
remained
a jesuit at heart and secretly did their
bidding
so what was weisshaupt's plan
first he was obsessed with secrecy he
proclaimed that
of all the means i know to lead men the
most effectual is a concealed mystery
the hankering of the mind is
irresistible
noting that the games and abuses of
secret societies were
without end he said i wanted to make use
of this
human weakness for a real and worthy
goal
the welfare of mankind simply put
vice health saw that men desire status
and offering them access to secrets real
or imagined
was a way to manipulate them he looked
for an existing secret society to serve
as a cover for his new one
weisshauf decided that none is fitter
than
freemasonry the public is accustomed to
it
expects little from it and therefore
takes little notice of it
he mocked ordinary freemasonry as a
frivolous business
but appreciated the keenness and zeal of
its members
and the way the lodges were knit
together by the secrecy of their union
and masonic lodges made excellent
recruiting grounds
so in 1777 weiss however joined a
masonic lodge
and demanded every illuminatus do
likewise
once initiated they were to attain
positions of leadership
and turn the lodges into vehicles for
illuminati propaganda and expansion
vice weishaupt also saw great value in
literary societies and libraries
the internet of their day he commanded
his order to establish
or infiltrate them so we may turn the
public mind
which way we will at the same time
the illuminati would monitor everything
appearing in print
weisshof said if a writer publishes
anything that attracts
notice but does not accord with our plan
we must endeavor to win him over or
decry him
though utterly contemptuous of religion
vice helped placed
a premium on recruiting clerics the most
wonderful thing of all he wrote is that
the distinguished
lutheran and calvinist theologians who
belong to our order
really believe that they see in it the
illuminati
the true and genuine sense of christian
religion
o mortal man is there nothing you cannot
be made to believe
weishaupt didn't forget the common man
he said
we must win the common people in every
corner
and he said this will be obtained
chiefly by
means of the schools and by open hearty
behavior
condescension popularity and toleration
of their prejudices
which we shall at leisure root out and
dispel
nor did he ignore women writing
there is no means of influencing men so
powerfully as by means of women
women should therefore be our chief
study we should insinuate ourselves into
their good opinion
give them hints of emancipation this he
argued
will cause them to work for us with zeal
without knowing that they do so still
vice house perfect world would be a
man's world
the head of every family will be the
patriarch
the priest and the unlettered lord of
his family
if this sounds like more deception and
manipulation
you're right weishaupt wouldn't argue
the ultimate goal was to make men free
and happy
but first they had to be made good and
that required manipulation trickery
even coercion well the illuminati would
be the enlightened
aristocracy of the new world order even
they
weren't equal or free a recruit
or novice was under the complete control
of his recruiter or
insinuator novices were told
what to read how to think and they kept
a
daily account of their every thought and
action
they also compiled detailed personal
histories
they had no secrets from their
insinuator and obeyed every command
without question initiates received a
special name
usually something classical vice house
was spartacus
curiously many picked names connected to
ancient mystery cults like
osiris pythagoras or atis
once a novice received initiation into
the next rank
the brethren of minerva he had truly
entered the illuminati there were also
two higher ranks minor and major
illuminatus
but weishaupt decreed that no
religionist
that is anyone retaining a scrap of
their old belief
could be admitted to them nor was there
any room for patriotism
absolute loyalty to the order and one's
illuminati superiors was the rule
the love of one's prince and of one's
country are incompatible with the
ultimate aims of the order
ordinary morality was also forbidden
calumnies poisonings assassinations
perjury treasons
and rebellions were not crimes if done
on the command of superiors and for the
good of the order
it's that old saying to the pure all
things are pure
it root it was antinomianism the
rejection of
all traditional rules and restrictions
the illuminati later instituted more
higher grades
unknown to the rank and file there were
scotch knights a nod to the masonic
scottish right
e-pups prefects national directors
national prefects and finally the grand
master
adam weishauft himself
illuminati propaganda insisted the order
would free men
from all religious prejudices cultivate
social virtues and lead them to a speedy
prospect of universal happiness
in a state of liberty and moral equality
freed from subordination rank and riches
weishaupt proclaimed my explanation is
accurate and complete my means are
effectual and
irresistible our secret association
works in a way nothing can withstand and
man shall soon be free and happy
if any of this sounds familiar it should
everything about vice health's
illuminism echoes the style
substance and promise of later communism
coincidence
or inheritance so how did vice house
plan work in practice
researchers like terry mellinson who
maintains the conspiracy archives
identifies about 450 confirmed
illuminati
other estimates range from 600 to 2000
regardless a huge increase from the
original five
still secret societies always emphasize
quality over quantity known illuminati
came almost exclusively from the 18th
century intelligentsia
lawyers academics physicians writers
and theologians abound among them was
johann funguetta
author of faust and one of the most
celebrated names in western literature
and guerta was confidential advisor to
another illuminatus
du carl august of saksa weimar
the illuminati roster includes an
astounding number of
barons and counts as well as more
important aristocrats
such as dukes and princes peasants
butchers and chimney sweeps are absent
jews pagans and ex-jesuits were
generally excluded
though exceptions were made the great
majority of illuminati were freemasons
most were germans but there were
brethren in austria
hungary switzerland france denmark and
even russia
there was an especially active cell in
naples italy
they played a guiding role in naples
short-lived
parthenopian republic in 1799
weishaupt focused on recruiting what
today we'd call
influencers or opinion shapers
illuminati brethren also mostly
represented the have
sums of enlightenment society as opposed
to the have nots
and have everythings they have some and
they wanted more
they embodied both ambition and
resentment
the same sort can be found in the
driver's seat of almost every revolution
marx lenin and castro would have felt
quite at home
despite the secrecy and conspiracy vice
house order
seemed to evaporate under scrutiny but
evaporated water
doesn't cease to exist it just goes
somewhere else
under pressure from the church carl
theodore of bavaria
banned the illuminati in 1784.
and again in 1785 yet again in 1787
and again in 1790 obviously suppression
wasn't easy
nor thorough outside bavaria
the order was mostly unscathed vice
houft
slipped away to nearby gota and he was
protected by its illuminatus prince
javier von zwaak one of weisshof's most
key lieutenants
was briefly jailed but escaped to paris
in 1786.
a year later so did johann bode who
weisshaupt made
executive secretary of the order the
exposure of the illuminati
was at least partly the work of a
disaffected brother
baron adolf von kinige who objected to
vice house stiff-necked in authoritarian
leadership
phone caniga was also one who accused
vysoft
of secret jesuitry
earlier i said that there were other
illuminati cults
well the term goes back to the mystery
cults of the roman empire
illuminism wasn't just a western concept
in the 1500s in what's now afghanistan
a brotherhood appeared the roshaniyah or
illuminated ones they had elaborate
very secret initiatory rituals
their founder and illuminated master was
a sufi
warrior mystic named pier bayezid khan
he decried the tyranny and spiritual
imperfections of secular rulers
including the powerful mogul emperor
pir baezid preached the overthrow of the
existing order
in the creation of a new world order
based on an egalitarian
communistic society men and women would
enjoy a paradise of perfect
equality under the benign guidance
of an enlightened elite sounds familiar
yes was the rashinia just part of what
author manley hall
called the larger movement
around the same time in spain there were
the alumbrados
or illuminatos they were first mentioned
in 1492
and were supposed to have come to spain
from italy
church officials suspected them of being
a survival of the earlier cathars
supporting the notion was the alum
brothers rejection of the catholic
church's authority and sacraments
following masters guided by visions of
angels and saints
the spanish illuminati sought mystical
knowledge
and ecstatic union with god once that
was attained
you could indulge lusts and other
desires all you wanted
without actually sinning to the pure
all things are pure yet again
this led to claims that the whole thing
was a cover for a sex cult
the inquisition intervened and the aldon
brothers were banned
in 1525 among those
implicated in the cult was none other
than the future founder of the jesuits
ignatius loyola
still the alombrados survived and spread
to france
in the early 1600s there they were
called
the illuminaes under the leadership of a
former catholic curate
pierre geron these illuminati attained a
following in piccardy
before being suppressed but not
destroyed
in 1635 and their appearance has an
interesting overlap with another secret
order
the rosicrucians in the early 1700s
yet another bunch of illuminaes appeared
in the remote
sevans region of southern france
they were part of a protestant revolt
against the french crown and the
catholic church
some of these illuminati fled to england
there they formed a sect called the
french prophets who
joined or infiltrated esoteric masonic
lodges
in 1754 back in france
an occultist named joachim martin de
pasquale
founded yet another illuminous sect
dubbed
the order of knights masons
elect priests of the universe their
doctrine was drawn from
ancient jewish mystical traditions the
kabbalah
ritual magic and even the doctrine of
swedish mystic emanuel swedenborg
they spread all the way to russia where
a cell thrived in moscow
until suppressed by catherine the great
in the 1790s
as a fixture of popular culture the
illuminati tale
kept evolving one of the first places it
might appear
is mary shelley's 1818 novel
frankenstein vice house hometown of
ingelstadt is the same place victor
frankenstein
makes his monster some see shelley's
tale
as an allegory for adam weishaup's
creation of the illuminati
a monster over which he lost control
certainly mary's husband poet percy
shelley was fascinated by the illuminati
researcher scott de hart argues that
percy shelley was himself an illuminatus
and the real author of the novel vice
house secret society went on to become a
stock villain in gothic pot boilers
jane austen mentions them half jokingly
in northanger abbey
they also come up in tolstoy's war and
peace
and have been referenced by contemporary
novelist umberto echo dan brown
and the marvel universe of comic book
fame
and then there are the video games and
music madonna's 2015 song
illuminati just continues the refrain
the illuminati have spawned endless
conspiracy theories as well
nista webster in her 1924 book secret
societies and subversive movements
resurrected claims of illuminati
influence behind the french revolution
and further link them to the bolsheviks
and pretty much every other radical
movement since the beginning of time
illuminati has become the blanket term
for
any shadowy elite bent on global
domination
what do henry kissinger queen elizabeth
david rockefeller
and arms magnet basil zaharov have in
common
they're all accused of being illuminati
in the 1990s british conspiracist david
ike went
further way further by turning the
illuminati into
shape-shifting lizard people from outer
space
what would adam weisshoft make of all
this
would he be disgusted that his plan for
making men
happy and free had been co-opted
corrupted and lampooned
or would he find satisfaction that the
name has survived
and that his secret society may have
achieved power and
influence beyond anything he could have
imagined
in 1776
[Music]
you